syphilis is a type of sexually
transmitted disease or infection it's
caused by tiny spiral or coiled bacteria
called tryponema pallidum
the first symptom you may notice is one
or more sores called shankers that are
usually painless and appear on the site
where the bacteria entered your body
without treatment the disease can
continue to progress through three or
more stages over a period of weeks
months or years
it can result in serious health problems
such as brain damage blindness or even
death
the good news is that syphilis can be
treated and cured with different forms
of an antibiotic called penicillin
usually one dose injected into your hip
or buttock is enough to clear the
infection
however if it has spread to other parts
of your body such as your eyes brain or
spinal cord you may need more than one
dose injected directly into your veins
people with serious infections such as
neurosyphilis may need to be treated in
the hospital
if penicillin can't be used other
antibiotics such as doxycycline can be
taken antibiotics work by killing the
bacteria that cause syphilis but it's
important to know that this treatment
won't fix any damage the disease has
already done to your body
you can reduce your risk of getting
syphilis if you only have sex with one
long-term partner who doesn't have sex
with other people and who has been
tested for syphilis and doesn't have it
and you can practice safer sex which
means taking steps before and during sex
to prevent you from getting or spreading
syphilis
for example using condoms correctly
every time you have sex can reduce your
risk
but if you come in contact with a sore
on an area of your partner's body not
covered by the condom you can still get
syphilis
the most reliable way to avoid getting
syphilis is to practice abstinence which
means not having vaginal anal or oral
sex
to find out more about the treatment and
prevention of syphilis talk to your
health care practitioner